the reason why I'm so excited about the
social use Lounge opportunity is because
that's what it really is it's a new
opportunity Las Vegas is known for
Reinventing itself and you know to the
point of our team the reset Vegas team
you know we're very excited to see what
these lounges can be and they can be
anything you know whether it's a food
and beverage opportunity with infused
cannabis meals so that we can introduce
this product to New non-endemic Markets
whether it's a movie theater whether
it's a bowling alley whether it's just
any kind of social environment what I
like to call the third place right first
place is home second place is work
what's the new third place and that
could be cannabis lounges a place where
we can just enjoy cannabis and it's
multiple iterations with other people
and that's something that I think people
really want to do for as long as I've
known you know past the duchy to the
left-hand side right I mean we are known
as being a socially active group and so
what better way to you know make Las
Vegas another reason to be here another
another destination for for this
cannabis tourist
um you know the sky's the limit